ERIK DEMAINE: Hi,
I'm Erik Demaine,
and I'm a professor of
computer science here at MIT.
And I'm one of three professors
in charge of this class
this semester-- 6.046
So I taught about half
of the lectures in the class.
Srini taught the other half.
And Nancy prepared
new problem sets.
And we all worked
together on everything
in the class pretty much.
We had, I think, 10 TAs
and then another 5 graders.
So it's a big teaching
infrastructure
to deliver algorithms
to 300 students.
My entire career at
MIT, all I have done
is taught different
forms of algorithms.
So 6.046 holds a place
particularly dear to my heart.
It's a class that's
evolved over time,
so there's an older
version of 6.046 on OCW
when algorithms in the
undergraduate level
was all taught in one semester,
which was exciting, but also
pretty intense and didn't
really go into a lot of depth.
So several years ago,
we split that class
into two-- 6.006, which is
introductory algorithms.
And the new 6.046, which
is this class, which
is intermediate algorithms
beyond what you could implement
in an hour-- things that
you have to think more about
and prove theorems about.
So 6.046 is sort of the
more theoretical counterpart
and gets into much more deeper
algorithms, and it's exciting.
And all of my research is
also around algorithms.
So this is me living the dream,
teaching the topic that I love.
And it's an exciting class.
This as an undergraduate
class, so the material
is stuff that I should
know really well.
But every time I
teach it, I find
that I learn it at
an even deeper level
and understand it better.
Also, because I try
to add in new topics
that I don't know so well,
so I learn them even better.
And that, in turn,
influences my research.
So once I understand
the basics really well,
I can apply them in new
and interesting ways
to solve problems I didn't
know how to solve before.
Algorithms are just so much fun.
Sometimes I start the class
with I'm Erik Demaine,
and I love the algorithms!
It's just such a-- it's
really fun material.
It's very creative.
It's almost like an
art form to come up
with a beautiful algorithm.
And this class teaches so
many different algorithms
that others have developed.
It's kind of like the
cream of the crop.
There's zillions out there,
so we can't cover all of them.
So we take out
representative examples
and find really cool,
really interesting,
or really beautiful algorithms.
And it's really fun
to cover them all
and to share that beauty
with the students.
I think I've taught this class
10 times in some version.
So it's been an adventure.
Every time is different.
And, of course, the last
time is always the best.
Next time will be even
better, hopefully.